the journey of emotion how long have you
been doing comedy for 15
so in those 15 years I want you to think
where your emotions were before you went
on stage when you started mmm your
emotions were when you get on stage now
it's [ __ ] two different [ __ ] world
yeah
now three months ago I can look these
both in the face when you came to see me
in Vegas yeah I'm gonna tell you
[ __ ] how I was damaged goods
yeah because it happens is the human
brain and sometimes our brain gets
[ __ ] Friday oh yeah everything not to
mention the reefer not to mention being
the father not to mention a thousand
variables but guess what [ __ ]
I'm back now yeah Tommy wise I'm back
because I got lost I watched John
Mulaney and I thought I wanted to be
John Mulaney he was a great [ __ ]
comic yeah great writer but guess what
I'll never be gentle Mulaney and I'll
never be the old one yeah and guess
what's even better
Silvan will never be John Mulaney don't
never be Joe Diaz why cuz he's [ __ ]
Theo von
yeah and Joe Diaz Joe PS and you know
what once I put that together like I'm
brand new and yet yeah like I feel like
I'm 20 [ __ ] eight now and I don't
want stayed like now you got a [ __ ]
problem last night I ate up that vein
you can't what every fight you insane
the main room I [ __ ] came out there
last night if I would have had a xanax
the seven minute mark I would've had to
take it can you feel my heart ready to
jump out of my chest
and that's what family is all about yeah
when you still feel that in your balls
that's what it's all about for months I
wasn't feeling the business part got to
be a business person sucks dick that the
[ __ ] numbers and this and that and
the tickets you know what I don't give a
[ __ ] you don't want to come see me no
[ __ ] come see me I'm still gonna do
what I do on stage I'm gonna be crazier
than ever
crazier than ever I don't give a [ __ ]
about society or how [ __ ] what you
can say and say that's got nothing to do
with me bro I'm a comic and I'm sick and
[ __ ] tired of what's going on
no more safety net yeah you know I was
making excuses up to you I'm not gonna
Comedy Store no more because I can't
work out new material
too bad work it out the county store
work it out if you bomb
you bomb yeah that's what Mitchell
intended that place to be but in my head
I'm like well they pay $25 I can't bomb
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you I gotta take a chance
on a something type rope if not I just
become one come from eating robot and
that's what I was becoming ah comedic
scared robot no man no no more if I'm in
the middle of the bit and I think
there's something that happened I'm
dropping it and if I forget the bit so
be it so be it
I'm going with my mind takes me now my
balls that connected to my heart I
connected to my brains and that's it
from now on I'm 55 what I got five six
years left to do time before you too old
and ugly to get on stage and people like
Joey let it go my mom will drive you to
[ __ ] gig the rest your life so over
comedy now like the Netflix special all
that stuff was like I said like this
thanks kid
yeah I'm like I'm done there is this
skin that comes in with the industry it
is yes it's not cool for guys like us no
it's not no it's not your thing don't
[ __ ] tell me what to say don't tell
me not to what no not the [ __ ] to say
number two I went to bro and I when I
bought every piece over the year I know
the last couple of years you know with
the podcast we have great families that
we've developed huh yeah they know my
love for comedy so people started
bringing me albums Bob Newhart out oh
wow and [ __ ] Lenny Bruce live from
Carnegie Hall and [ __ ] they brought
me all the Richard Pryor almost a good
one bicentennial [ __ ] and the good was
something I said or you know the [ __ ]
crazy those are raw Richard Pryor Wow I
forced myself to put him back on the
turntable [ __ ] [ __ ] videos yeah [ __ ]
watch his [ __ ] specials I mean think
about it in your head put it on video
look how they did it they would do a
tour and take the bit the best way came
out you could hear the bit end and then
it'd start all over again
so the albums were brilliant yeah where
are we doing that yeah where aren't we
doing that I don't want a special ever
again
yeah ever again do I want to shoot a
special you know it's a vowel it's just
out yeah I want you to listen I want
them to hear the glasses I want them to
hear the [ __ ] breathing I want them
that's what I'm
to me yeah the specials they forgot how
to shoot there Oh 100%
they forgot if I can uh looking Lenny
Bruce everybody tries to be avant-garde
now they're showing you the audience
they want to show you a fire that just
show the stand-up from the waist to the
head doing stand-up yeah don't show me
the [ __ ] audience we just act like I
watched somebody special
he was bombing the audience was that
wasn't laughing yeah and you can hear
like this laughter if you laugh you go
like this you move back and forth when
you laugh this audience was stiffer than
[ __ ] yeah you can hear the laugh track
you know Netflix is about to drop about
47 new specials that means nobody's
gonna get to watch them we're all gonna
be caught in a mess yeah what were you
gonna do well thanks for watching that
video right there that was a beautiful
little segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe share subscribe